they call it balling on a budget for a
reason because if you're not budgeting
you ain't balling let's talk money all
we talk is money
all we talk is money all we talk is
money
[Music]
once you enter the workforce you're
playing the money game and it's
essential
to have a game plan for your money
according to a gallup poll
two-thirds of americans don't do a
budget and two-thirds of americans live
paycheck to paycheck
coincidence i think not a budget
is the key to maximizing your net worth
budgeting takes you from surviving
to thriving you don't want to float you
want to swim baby
now i get it the thought of budgeting is
not fun at all
but neither is living paycheck to
paycheck you want to stop scraping by
and start building real wealth
well budgeting is the first step the
biggest barrier between you
and a budget is that you can't handle
the truth
you need to be honest and accurate as to
what you're making
and what you're spending if you score 20
points but you give
up 25 you're gonna lose every single
time
your budget make sure that you don't
lose and if you're living paycheck to
paycheck
you got a budget man so how does one
budget well first you got to figure out
your income
minus your expenses calculate what's
coming in the door every month
minus what's going out the door every
month get to know your cash flow
the more you know about your cash flow
the better
then you got to learn the 50 30 20 rule
50 percent goes to your needs
30 goes to your wants and 20 goes to
your financials
like saving and paying off debt while
there's insurance
cell phone bills and of course lattes
the big three needs are housing
transportation and food and beverage so
let's say you're making 4k a month
2k goes to your needs like housing and
transportation 1200 bucks goes to your
wants
like travel and shopping but 800 bucks
should go to your savings
and paying off debt the more you can
move from your wants
to your financials the better off you'll
be now to budget
properly you need to understand the
difference between gross
and net gross is the total and net is
the total
after taxes like my boy drake once said
in his song
worst behavior opened up the mail
staring at a check
it's enough to make you throw up man
it's gross what i net
don't forget uncle sam's cut put the net
in net worth my two cents
you have to know how much it costs to be
you add it up
look back at it and figure out how to
make it cost less
to be yourself cut the fat on one of the
big three that's housing
transportation or f b that's where most
of your money goes
and the best time to do it is on the
first of the month
just catch your checks and get up like
my boy bone once said
and every month is different you got
birthdays valentine's day christmas
hanukkah even
so be flexible your april budget is
going to be a lot different
than your august budget so figure out
the best way to handle
each month and write it down if you're
old school
use a pen and paper if you're new school
use an app
but do something budgeting is not mental
math
so don't go broke trying to prove you're
not broke
tell your money what to do don't let it
tell you
what to do and budget like brady tom
brady
has a game plan every single game so you
need to do a budget
every single month that's 12 budgets a
year and the first of the month is game
day
baby be the go to budgeting and you're
well on your way to financial wins
and if you're still unsure about
budgeting well
save that money
thanks for watching this video on
budgeting do you do a budget every
single month
let me know below in the comments what
your budget looks like and as always
save that money all we talk is